en los vídeos pasados ya hablamos acerca
de la elasticidad de la demanda que es
un concepto para un bien como al
modificar el precio de ese bien
porcentualmente se modifica
porcentualmente la cantidad de unidades
demandadas ahorita de lo que quiero
hablar es de la elasticidad cruzada de
la demanda elasticidad
cruzada de la demanda de la demanda
demanda y la idea es muy similar sólo
que ahora vamos a involucrar más de un
bien y por eso se llama cruzada entonces
vamos a ver algunos ejemplos a le vamos
a empezar con un par de aerolíneas la
aerolínea 1 y la aerolínea 2 y
supondremos que venden el mismo vuelo no
se fija mos el vuelo mérida méxico es un
vuelo igualito tiene la misma comodidad
la misma duración son vuelos idénticos
pensemos que inicialmente cuesta mil
pesos que esta aerolínea vende 200
boletos y esta de acá también lo venden
mil pesos y cuesta 200 perdón y se
venden 200 bueno que sucedería si estos
si este precio de acá aumentara o sea si
ahora estos mil pesos fueran digamos mil
50 pesos pues vamos a pensar un poquito
mira a uno ya dos ofrecen exactamente el
mismo vuelo entonces digamos si luciano
quiere viajar de mérida a méxico pues va
a comparar a vos va a decir son
exactamente el mismo pero este es más
caro entonces mejor me voy por esta
aerolínea de acá
de esta forma pues todas las personas
van a dejar de comprarle a aa1 ahora ya
no se vendería nada aquí y aquí se
venderían 400 este precio sigue igualito
verdad mil muy bien entonces esta idea
es importante un cambio en el precio de
acá modificó la cantidad de este lado
entonces vamos a calcular una
elasticidad cruzada de la siguiente
manera vamos a empezar calculando los
cambios porcentuales de precio acá y de
cantidad acá pero como lo hemos estado
haciendo antes estos cambios
porcentuales dependen uno de los
extremos sino del promedio es decir
nuestra cantidad base para hacer el
porcentaje va a ser el promedio de los
dos extremos entonces veamos qué sucede
pues acá este precio pasó de ser 1000 a
ser 1050 entonces tuvo un cambio de 50 y
por tanto tuvo un cambio porcentual
cambio porcentual le voy a poner así del
precio 1 fue igual a 50 dividido entre
mil 25 hábitat vemos cuánto da y de este
lado tuvimos un cambio de 200 a 400 o
sea de 200 y por tanto el cambio por
pero ahora en la cantidad 2 fue igual a
200 200 dividido entre el promedio de
200 y 400 o sea 300 vamos a ver cuánto
nos da esto de acá saquemos la
calculadora déjame borrar esto de acá
nos queda 50 dividido entre mil 25
20.048 o sea 4.8 por ciento 4.8 por
ciento y de este lado es 200 entre 300
es dos tercios sociales 66.666 16% le
voy a poner 67% vamos entonces antes
para la elasticidad precio de la demanda
lo que hacíamos era dividir este cambio
porcentual entre este cambio porcentual
pero hacer observa que este menos 200
niños importa lo que nos va a importar
ahora es este cambio de 200 en la
aerolínea 2 entonces como ya hacemos
para calcular la elasticidad cruzada de
la demanda pues así la elasticidad
cruzada de la demanda y le voy a poner
algunas aclaraciones
de la cantidad 2 con respecto
con respecto al precio 2 al precio 1
perdón entonces cambiamos esta cantidad
porque se cambió este precio es igual a
y es casi la misma idea que con la
elasticidad es el cambio porcentual de
la cantidad entre el cambio porcentual
del precio pero aquí arriba es la
cantidad 2 y aquí abajo es el precio 1
por eso se llama elasticidad cruzada
relacionados bienes vamos a ver cuánto
nos da tendríamos que hacer 67 entre 4.8
entonces es 67 entre 4.8
es 13.95 le voy a poner 14 vale entonces
es igual a 14 estoy aquí es un numerito
observe es un número positivo antes con
la elasticidad teníamos que sacar
valores absolutos para que nos dieran
números positivos porque casi siempre
nos daban valores negativos pero aquí
quedo positivo y no sólo quedo positivo
sino que quedó muy grande verdad 14 es
más o menos grandes muy arriba de 1 y
eso se debe a que estos dos bienes están
muy relacionados de hecho voy a
escribirlo por acá son casi sustitutos
perfectos
casi sustitutos sustitutos perfectos
perfectos hecho como lo planteamos
prácticamente son sustitutos perfectos y
de hecho un cambio incluso muy muy muy
pequeñito en el precio hasta de un peso
podría generar este mismo fenómeno y por
tanto como el cambio habrá aquí es muy
pequeño esto sería muy pequeño
estaríamos dividiendo entre algo muy
pequeño y este número podría hacerse muy
muy grande entonces lo que sucede es que
con los sustitutos perfectos perfecto le
voy a poner aquí
para poner aquí sustitutos y sustitutos
perfectos tenemos que la elasticidad
cruzada de la demanda se va a infinito y
aquí como como son sustitutos uno de
otro bueno no perfectos nada más por ser
sustitutos tenemos que la elasticidad es
positiva vamos a ver otro ejemplo déjame
pasar acá abajo supongamos que ahora yo
estoy vendiendo mi libro mi libro
electrónico
voy a poner así el libro y yo le podría
poner ebook pero esto lo voy a poner ti
para que quede en español y aquí le voy
a poner lectores electrónicos
lectores electrónicos también podría
poner ereader pero le voy a poner en
español entonces tengo libros
electrónicos y lectores electrónicos y
supongamos que actualmente así como
están las cosas estoy vendiendo digamos
500 la cantidad de libros electrónicos
de mi libro que estoy vendiendo es de
500 al mes y pensemos que los lectores
electrónicos ahorita están
pues vamos a ponerle mil pesos vale
entonces qué sucedería si los lectores
electrónicos bajan y ahora esto
disminuye a 800 pesos
pues no sé o sea aquí aquí tendría una
baja de 200 pesos y no sé o sea a lo
mejor como ahora tenemos más personas
con lectores electrónicos porque ahora
cuestan menos verdad y como ahora la
gente tiene más dinero pues la gente
puede gastar más en mi libro electrónico
y entonces digamos que que pasa de ser
500 a hacer 700 vale o sea ahora en vez
de vender 500 vendo 700 veamos qué
sucede con la actividad cruzada de la
demanda en este caso pues vamos a hacer
cambios porcentuales entonces aquí
tenemos el cambio porcentual de este
precio de acá es igual a menos 200
dividido entre el promedio entre el
promedio de 800 y 1000 que es 900 y de
este lado tenemos pues 200 éste es más
200 verdad dividido entre el promedio de
500 y 700
a ver lo voy a poner cambio porcentual
en el precio que iba a poner cambio
porcentual en la cantidad y entonces
aquí es 200 dividido entre 600 muy bien
cuánto nos queda estoy acá es un tercio
verdad un tercio un tercio y estoy acá
pues vamos a ver cuánto nos queda es
igual a este 33%
etcétera verdad y el otro nos queda es
200 ahorita le pongo al menos entre 900
es esos son muchos 23 puntos 22 222 o
sea 22 por ciento entonces ahí nos va a
quedar 22 por ciento 22 por ciento y acá
tuvimos un cambio a ojo pero estás -22%
verdad y acá tuvimos un cambio de 33.3
por ciento entonces qué va a suceder con
la elasticidad cruzada de la demanda
usted dejo de tarea que verifiques que
va a dar negativa aunque ya sabes que a
lo mejor a lo mejor lo voy a hacer de
una vez si quieres intentarlo tú mejor
ponle pausas y lo voy a hacer de una vez
para acabar bien con los ejemplos
entonces en este caso tendríamos que la
elasticidad la elasticidad cruzada de la
demanda de la demanda la de su parte una
pe de la demanda es igual al cambio
porcentual en la cantidad de libros
electrónicos cambio porcentual en la
cantidad dividido entre el cambio
porcentual del precio cambio porcentual
del precio o sea sería igual
sería igual a 33.3 dividido entre menos
22 vamos a ver cuánto nos da entonces es
33.3 ay no sé qué dicen 33.3 dividido
entre 22 ahorita le pongo el menos y eso
es 1.51 36
bajo esto de aquí es igual a 1.51 muy
bien eso está eso está re bueno entonces
aquí ya tenemos este cambio porcentual
este cambio porcentual y ahora nos quedó
negativo nos quedó menos 1.51 eso lo que
nos dice es que ahora pues como como que
estos dos bienes están relacionados esto
de aquí son bienes complementarios
complementarios
y justo la elasticidad cruzada de la
demanda no refleja teniendo un valor
negativo vale entonces para bienes
complementarios la elasticidad cruzada
de la demanda es negativa finalmente qué
sucede si tenemos bienes no relacionados
no se pensemos así por decir algo que no
tiene nada que ver este la cantidad de
pelotas de basquetbol con el precio de
las pelotas de basquetbol con mi libro
electrónico entonces voy a poner aquí
pelotas de básquet de básquet básquet
y qué cambio digamos no sé la pelota
estaba en 200 pesos y ahora cuesta pues
vamos a ponerle 180 pesos entonces aquí
tuvimos un cambio verdad de 20 pesos
podríamos calcular el cambio porcentual
aquí disminuyó 20 pesos podríamos
calcular el cambio porcentual pero
realmente realmente mi libro no va a
cambiar en nada o sea mi libro ahora va
a pasar de tener 500 a seguir teniendo
500 entonces este cambio va a ser de 0 y
entonces puedes hacer las cuentitas para
ver cuánto es este cambio porcentual eso
te lo recomiendo para practicar pero
independientemente de cuánto sea la
elasticidad cruzada de la demanda
elasticidad cruzada de la demanda va a
ser igual al cambio porcentual en la
cantidad de libros entre el cambio
porcentual en el precio verdad pero no
importa que tengamos aquí abajo aquí va
a tener tenemos su full pero aquí arriba
vamos a tener un cero entonces estoy
aquí va a ser cero de este modo una
elasticidad cruzada de la demanda y
igual a cero pues está relacionada con
que los bienes no tengan nada que ver
entre sí
bueno ya nada más para resumir vámonos
para acá arriba entonces la elasticidad
cruzada de la demanda se calcula como un
porcentaje de la cantidad de bueno
cambio porcentual de la cantidad de un
bien entre cambio porcentual del precio
de otro bien si es si es éste positiva
quiere decir que los bienes son
sustitutos uno de otro si es negativa
complementarios si es cero entonces no
tienen nada que ver esos dos bienes y si
se va es infinitos son más y más
sustitutos y acá si se vean a menos
infinitos son más y más complementarios
bueno entonces espero que te haya
gustado nos vemos hasta la próxima